Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, je vais répondre
à la question d'Audrey, qui me demande :
« Que pensez-vous des intervenants "blancs" dans
les communautés autochtones? Par exemple : DPJ,
services sociaux et enseignement. »
Audrey, c'est évidemment une opinion personnelle
et multiple, parce que je pense
que les intervenants, qu'ils soient blancs,
qu'ils soient liés à l'immigration
ou qu'ils soient autochtones, sont extrêmement
nécessaire, parce qu'on a besoin
de services dans les communautés.
Cependant, il faut faire très attention
de ne pas arriver avec des idées préconçues
sur les communautés. Ce qui a vraiment
pu être très néfaste dans les communautés,
c'est d'arriver avec ce qu'on appelle
la mentalité du sauveur : on va les sauver,
on va les aider, mais sans jamais consulter
les communautés, sans jamais s'intéresser
non plus à la culture de fond,
à l'histoire familiale et à la façon
de faire dans les communautés.
Présentement, beaucoup de services de la DPJ
sont repris par les communautés.
Donc, ça montre que ces services-là
sont nécessaires. Simplement, il faut aussi
les rendre culturellement sécuritaires.
Beaucoup de personnes qui vont venir
à intervenir, que ce soit des médecins
ou que ce soit des infirmiers
ou des policiers, vont avoir des contacts
extrêmement intimes avec des familles
d'origine autochtone, que ce soit
d'une nation ou une autre, qui vont être très différentes.
D'une nation à l'autre, c'est très différent.
Et surtout, ils arrivent avec
leurs propres appréhensions, leurs propres
interprétations de ce qu'est la culture
des Premières Nations et, des fois,
même avec leurs
propres à priori.
Souvent, ce qu'on remarque, c'est que ceux qui s'intègrent bien à la vie communautaire vont rester là
pendant plusieurs années et ceux avec qui
ça ne fonctionne pas se sentent très isolés
et repartent au bout d'un an.
Il y a quand même une nécessité
de connaître l'histoire de fond
des communautés. Moi, peu importe
l'origine du travailleur
ou de l'intervenant, tant qu'il est formé
et qu'il est sensibilisé aux questions
et aux enjeux autochtones je pense que
c'est nécessaire.
Jusqu'au jour où, on l'espère, on n'aura
plus autant besoin de ces services-là
dans nos communautés.
Alors, en espérant avoir bien répondu
à la question,
n'hésitez pas à partager les vidéos
et n'hésitez pas surtout à nous envoyer
des questions à Parole autochtone.
Je vous souhaite une belle semaine.